stop it
[Music]
welcome back to another awesome episode
of the careful boys today we have subin
in the building
and also we got Anthony back after three
years Anthony
like the the length gets longer why were
you gone so long yeah it's been six
years yeah that's been [__] 84 months
um you were dancing and [__] all over
the world you have an accent now yeah oh
really do I really Indonesia
Anthony was dancing to sell cars
selling cars yes he told us that you had
a gig at a car dealership it was a grand
opening it was a grand opening for a car
dealership
I didn't know Anthony was [__]
selling yeah he was promoting a new
Volvo dealership that was opening in in
[__] Indonesia though yeah
micronesian wow
um no I was in China I was in the
mainland China
Go China we need more positive China
stuff on here I love China people oh
China people I like China dollars too
I like China people I like I like adding
unnecessary Chinese characters of
American films
Chinese food oh I love Chinese food nice
my friend came out with this hot sauce
from
um the Jang Jang reason uh region it's
[__] I'll give you guys some it's bomb
it's like the chili sauce thing oh yeah
the chili crunch one oh chili crisps how
is Lujan dude so Luhan is uh is amazing
he's the artist I was choreographing for
out there
um this I might have mentioned it before
this was the a crazy crazy experience
because his tour was supposed to happen
in 2021 the beginning of 2021 and this
is when I went in the end of 2020 I went
to China to work on this tour
I quarantined by myself during this time
for like two weeks I spent Christmas by
myself in corn they still make you
quarantine no this was this was in 2020.
because that's the protocol back then
yeah that's great did your mind go crazy
just being in a hotel room you know
what's weird the idea of needing to do
it sucks but when you're there and you
have to experience it it's kind of like
a sick life experience yeah kind of he
loved Colvin yeah that's a that's a very
strong way to put it but he loves it
wait every day in the hotel it doesn't
drive you nuts like I can't even go
outside and there's a part of being nuts
that like feels kind of like interesting
because you develop like a unique
routine and you you know what I mean
like wait you couldn't leave the door
like oh can you open the window and go
it was like more like a prison than it
was a hotel wasn't like a nice hotel by
any means it's like it's like when they
put you up in semi close to the airport
and everybody's in hazmat suits when you
first get off it's so funny to talk
about Kobe right now but yeah even when
you go with like let's say your
significant other they put you in two
hotels oh that's a [__] and then
both of you guys are like that for two
weeks yeah that's [__] what do you
do do you get internet you get internet
uh at least you get internet yeah but I
was lucky because I was still uh able to
like you know my my hosts are not host
but my homie out there Coco shoot I was
still hitting them every day to like
order [__] for me because like the food
that they give you is like cafeteria
lunch food they only give it to you like
twice a day they like knock on your door
they get uh they send it over to you and
then they did not defeat the purpose of
quarantine the food could be brought in
all the time let's not question certain
things that are hey hey One China map
okay what I'm trying to do chill relax
but anyways uh so I'm gonna be important
thing about myself the quarantine is the
the whole point is the door is like this
but if like the doors like this like
every [__] hour like how much but
they're in hazmat suits twice a day they
come in and they test you twice a day up
in the nose yeah [__] that it was
annoying now my Chinese nose
so uh the point is we I finally like I
spent six weeks out there in in 2020 all
through 2020 uh the beginning of 2021
and then we get to like the first
location where we're doing the tour stop
number one uh on Thursday the show's on
Saturday show number one the Thursday
that we're there we get approval from
everybody in the city the high
Chancellor of the city and stuff like
that we're like good to go the stage is
built we're rehearsing on stage we're
like right to the Finish Line on it and
then on Friday an official from Beijing
flies in and it cancel the whole thing
what whoa so like it just felt like we
had spent months working on this thing
like the Chinese fauci came in basically
well is it because or is it because of
hip-hop because I remember for a minute
they're like
it's not coping related it's just
hip-hop no more dancing are you hip-hop
on a rocket Bang Bang the Boogie the
Bang Bang the Boogie stop it you know
how they say hip-hop don't stop yeah not
today China is stopped okay there was
like a famous like hip-hop rapper who
had like committed adultery like another
famous yeah so then that turned into
they're like it's degenerate culture
yeah man what is that that's American
Hip-Hops so for the people that don't
understand who Luhan is what's the
equivalent american-wise artist is it
like a Michael Jordan the way that
Jackson uh describes it is he's like the
Justin Bieber of China whoa this guy's
got like a huge huge following cult
following yeah like really really huge I
mean he came from uh he came from Exo
which is a a K-Pop group as well
did he speak Korean he speaks Korean oh
wow and so but then when you said I'm
[__] better than y'all and then he
went solo and then yeah like kind of
like Beyonce
what other words did he use yeah she's
way better than y'all so he just went
back to China to be with his family
stuff like that and then he went solo
yeah he was doing solos uh he's been
doing solo stuff uh this is his third
tour
um he he does like TVs dramas and like
movies and stuff like that as well he's
major that dude is on like Billboards
for like Gucci and [__] like in the city
is he from Wuhan because I'll be sick
Luhan from Wuhan dude that's good
branding for him
for his name being Luan did he get [__]
no I don't think so I think only
Americans think like that yeah all right
and uh so so we got all the way to the
finish line and wasn't able to cross it
so that was like a really devastating
moment uh and then it was just kind of
like indefinitely ended so how did you
feel at that time to like have all this
prep and then
cancel it I think there's a like as a
Creator when you're like prepping
forever to like put this show together
and then you don't get to show the
audience it's like the biggest deflated
feeling that's true it's just so
disappointing because you're not even
doing it for yourself you're literally
doing it for the fans that's true at
least at least it was happening to
everybody that would suck if it was just
you guys and there was no covet it was
it was definitely happening to everybody
it did definitely feel like though that
they were making an example out of him
because he's such a huge star that if he
can't do it no one else was able to yeah
that's true and so it was like it felt
it felt really devastating at that time
because it's like if it was a small guy
like wuwon or something and then like
he's trying to do his music and then
they're like nobody care about we want
he only only he has 50 people in his
audience
Wu one sounds like a Mexican guy in the
Wu-Tang Clan
you know are you gonna get a chance to
do a redo well that's the thing that's
what I came back for this time that's it
so this two and a half years this was
the dude like yeah they're like hey
we're bringing the tour back so I was
already like I'm not gonna believe you
until like contracts are signed and I
fly over there because my heart has
already settled for like two and a half
years of just thinking that it was all
gone right and you're gonna have to do
it again that's a big gap but here's the
here's the crazy thing that was super
super sick
um last time we're like to the wire when
you're putting together like a whole
show big production like so many moving
Parts like to the day of you're still
working on this transition changing this
costume figuring out this moment or
whatever right who knows what the I know
what those dance moves like exactly
because you're a pro sort of not really
and then we go this year but it's the
same show we're just finally getting it
prepped to get back on stage so I showed
up and it was like 90 done already
so this was a completely night and day
different experience because we got to
go in there and it wasn't like chill
where we weren't still working every day
we're still doing like seven hour
rehearsals every day but it wasn't
figuring out [__] like crazy it was like
fine tuning making things a little bit
better you know what I mean kind of
thinking about things that we didn't
have the luxury to think about last time
because we were just trying to get the
meat and the bulk together now we're
like really getting the sauces into the
accessories and then because there's way
less stress we got to just
enjoy ourselves through the process so
much more so I ended up having a [__]
sick time over there because we were
just
me and Lou we were just going out to
dinner like every single night he was
taking me on this like whole [__]
Beijing tour of like the finest dining
wow I was so lucky out there he took me
to like a [__] three Michelin star
restaurant and this was just like on a
Thursday what kind of food was that yeah
Turtles
did you eat scorpion in there no we went
to a peking duck place in Beijing and
they had scorpion but we didn't order it
the crazy thing I did out there was
[__] bugs what kind of bugs
so you ate bugs but not scorpion I ate
them in my sleep all the time but you
went to Michelin stars trying to eat
bugs no it also just happened to eat
spiders baby
man that's kind of whack in the mission
Star Restaurant you're eating things
like [__] pigeon that's cool pigeons
what'd you think of pigeon was it bomb
so this is like like deep fried bugs
they're like on the trees and they make
these crazy sounds and [__] like that
like cicadas
that's the Michelin
[Music]
he was just talking about eating
scorpion I was like why what is that is
that a regular snack over there like
eating a bag of Flamin Hot Cheetos and
in a particular City in Guangzhou like
they basically this place this city is
known for eating like almost anything so
they don't need no raid or anything
they could read everyone just eats oh
[__] we got a lot of ants oh everybody
come here
[Laughter]
no problem
is that how it went down here
oh my god dude he's like oh [__] ABS
it's like a [__] line of coke hey I'm
it was kind of tasty it was it good it
was actually good it was really crunchy
I'm sure they prepared a specific way
yeah they're like deep frying it in some
crazy sauces and stuff when they season
like one time I had crickets and when
they seasoned it right yeah they did
like a honey glaze thing too if it goes
it like this big it was like this
[__] big it actually was a bomb bro
just tastes like dry shrimp yeah or like
you know those those uh dried fish that
like the the sweet and salty ones that
you get from the Chinese markets yeah
yeah yeah like those ones that's what it
tastes like but bugs look like [__] yeah
supposed to have good protein it's
protein it's protein you know this whole
movement everyone's like don't eat pig
don't eat cow eat a [__] meal worm
you know that thing like everyone's like
eating that's a movement that's a move
man I'm done with eating bugs too the uh
the the eco-friendly people they're like
eat the bugs I have a very like I want
to try everything once for the most part
I still don't want to eat like I don't
want to eat like cats and dogs but like
I don't want to still try everything
once like like fried come
oh you guys want to try that of course
your mind goes there the guy who brought
in penis flavored chips from Europe I
ate fish come
yeah it's it's in sushi it's you
probably ate it too uh it's called
akimono oh yeah yeah you probably ate it
too I did eat fish come fish
[__] come sack isn't that what uni is
technically or is that ovaries that's
ovaries ovaries that's cool yeah I'll
eat ovaries bro I'm not gonna eat [__]
bro
that's where I draw the line
what do you got the mission Starbucks I
like ovaries better they had like the
sickest [__] no they're they're main
dish or one of the Delicacies really was
is like this young pigeon and it was
Chinese cuisine or yeah it was Chinese
how big is a young pigeon I'm gonna show
you a photo too it was like literally um
this big but like that was half of it
and then the other half it's it's like
the whole thing you see like it sawed
down the middle why do they like to do
[__] like that's crazy man did they
bring it in a cage no no
when I was a kid and this [__]
had a [__] pigeon and it came
literally like this yeah it's like that
but cut in half yeah and I'm like that
is not appetizing to me to them I think
they liked it but I was like what did it
taste is good it's just bomb it's just
[__] chicken honestly it's just like
a really good seasoning yes imagine that
chicken that that's just done really
really well though you know what I'm
saying it has to be because chicken
liver they had they brought out this
chicken liver that was like so it melts
in your mouth like butter
nasty man they had they had this uh pork
and cuttlefish sausage that was all
black it was like a black sausage it was
just [__] delicious it was good
really so good now I'm gonna lie Chinese
food looks like [__] yeah there was this
episode of Bizarre Foods where they went
to China and I forgot what city but it
was a restaurant that specializes in all
thick so it's just every so every plate
is a different dick like Pig thing
[__] tiger dick whatever dick right
all kinds of Dick yeah and then they
just prepare in different ways yeah
there's a lot of penis that's available
I don't know maybe they call it
McDonald's or something I don't know
Chinese people are weird man they just
like there's just no way
[Laughter]
Oscar Maya wait so it's true then those
videos of these Chinese guys stealing
pigeons and taking them in the bag and
going in the back of bro that [__]
happens another different countries yeah
yeah it's definitely not just China do
you think pound for pound Chinese people
are the best at like eating all
everything I mean I think the better you
get at cooking the broader your food is
that's oh that's a good art it's a very
positive way no no that's true that's a
positive way of saying they're [__]
weird but China but Chinese food like by
far out of all the regions like you put
them all together it's it is probably
it's up there bro well you gotta also
think they got so many people yeah and
they have so much land of diverse like
from the north all the way down to the
South they got so much terrain and
ecosystem so they're gonna have a lot
they also got hella history so they've
been cooking like that forever but they
make most of the like the food other
countries did other countries did too
but they stopped doing it that's the
difference so like Europeans ain't so
[__] crazy [__] like there's pictures
like them having feasts with the whole
whole ass duck just out the same way I
feel like Europeans don't even eat food
anymore they just smoke cigarettes all
the time they just smoke cigarettes and
coffee and they have
what is that place called Phoenix in
they just have a plate full of duck
tongues yeah that shit's good is it oh
yeah Chinese people crazy oh man how
many ducks you gotta kill to get a plate
full of duck tongue there's only one
tongue per duck
we out here
we'll eat like chicken so frequently and
we're always focused on like the
drumstick or the breasts but then it's
the organs and stuff that's usually the
most nutritious Parts yeah I'm not gonna
touch that though dude I'm not gonna
touch it you know there's a whole thing
now with uh the carnivores saying like
ah we're gonna eat all of it and then
now there's like a bunch of white folks
eating all the organs now oh like when
they hunt deer and they eat that's kind
of awesome because that's literally the
most nutritious bar because there's a
lot of the B8 actually they like ground
beef more than steaks because ground
beef has like organs cartilage all that
stuff so they're actually saying ground
beef it's actually it's all like whipped
into a slurry bro ground beef is
delicious it is oh you know I just
recently found out some [__] you gotta
be careful where you get your ground
beef from because they put hella fillers
in there man it's not just protein what
is in there there's just you'll watch
when they make it there's like [__]
powders and all these preservatives and
[__] that they throw in there where's
this at dude I'll show you a pedigree
pedigree yeah I'll show you dog food
[Laughter]
have you seen uh what a turducken is
yeah yeah they stuff a [__] all those
three you know birds in one and I'm like
that's kind of Chinese but it's European
yeah it is okay besides eating really
delicious top-notch food what else did
you do while you're out there yeah
um so because I was living such a well
number one it was such a
emotional Journey just coming back to a
project that I I felt such a a downward
slope emotionally from last time and
then to come back and feel such an
upward experience even getting to the
first weekend show in Beijing I wasn't I
was emotional you know what I mean it
was like super dope and luhan's like way
more than an artist I choreographer
consider them like family you know like
a brother like because we've gone
through a lot of pain together he was
the guy who had to tell me he like
brought me from the rehearsal stage in
2021 to the back room and he was like I
have to tell you something and I was
like man that sounds really heavy he's
like the Show is canceled we just sat
there and silenced together for a long
time you know what I mean so that sucks
I think when you go through something
really hard with somebody you actually
way closer with them than when you know
everything's just good so that's true
did you get paid though for all those
rehearsals and everything I asked me in
a couple months when the show's finished
and then you know we should be oh the
show's not finished yet no they're still
going on right now no I'm talking about
20 20. like when you first went so
that's the thing oh oh because I we
didn't finish it contractually I
couldn't get paid for the rest of it
which was which was another level of
like man this is I turned into a gift
you know and you're constantly you know
like I ain't about the money because you
need to like self-preservation otherwise
you'd just be really really sad and
upset yeah but that was another reason
why I was like damn this is a tough loss
the day before we don't get to like go
to the first show therefore I don't get
to get paid for like XYZ yeah so you're
so you're not part of the performance
you're just part of creating and cool I
was just choreographer so now your your
job is technically done they just go on
tour yeah and finish off the tour that's
what I was gonna say two years how did
you remember the dance moves
how did dance choreographers before
video remember dance moves because you
know musicians they got the notes
um so they could write it that's a very
good question but the ballerina people
and the dance people how did they write
it down yeah how do they write down
anything do they do stick figures answer
us stop lying to it yeah there's the the
five Palm technique Book pamphlet that
you have to write every movie you never
saw those books with the footprints on
them nope is it like dancer Braille yeah
those shoe prints and the arrows that's
how you do it that's what I'm like I
don't know because they still
choreographed these masses you know the
game like the game the game just danced
or they got the little stick figures
Just Dance there's got to be like
ballerina sheet music huh yeah that's
what the hieroglyphics were trying to
tell you oh they're actually dance moves
yeah that's what it's always been it's
just a choreographer I just wrote on the
wall that's why they say that's like an
Egyptian
I'm done now um so we're gonna buy us
when you get your money right uh maybe
get you guys some merch from the tour no
I want Chinese bugs you want some
Chinese bugs I want some Luhan merch bro
I want flaming hot crickets I will say
though uh just at least as a final note
that you know a lot of like pop stars
and people that get like famous from
like those you know uh groups and
whatnot like not necessarily all of them
can hella sing like that's just the
truth of it you know what I mean but
this will can [__] sing yeah so like
it's it's way different when you're you
become truly a fan of the person's music
I'm a [__] fan of this because you
like the music so you more feeling yeah
you're just sitting there in the concert
actually like I enjoy this concert
didn't you work with him on hot blood
Dance Crew I did that's how that's how
we met which is and then we just kept
going they were doing uh can't just were
doing this TV show in China like a dance
TV show that was like super popular and
then me and Hawk went out to work on a
different TV show that was like
competing with that one oh yeah that TV
show also won again
[Laughter]
would you say you love Luhan I do I love
it